se dio a conocer pues Cuáles son los los
galardonados de este de este año se hizo
en la ciudad de estrasburgo 1500
personas allí presentes puede contarles
fueron 44 restaurantes los que fueron
premiados ascendidos por llamarlo así 40
39 ellos recibieron su primera estrella
cuatro de ellos su segunda estrella pero
en realidad lo que quizás ha causado más
digamos sorpresas que están tan solo un
restaurante recibió tres estrellas un
restaurante en la isla de noamut esto es
en el Atlántico francés se llama la
mahini es un chef muy joven Alexander
cuyo quien se lleva este honor teniendo
en cuenta que la semana pasada se dio a
conocer también que dos de los grandes
chefs franceses perdieron sus tres
estrellas entre ellos agua que a lo
largo de veintiún años había conservado
estas tres estrellas y de hecho en
noviembre del año pasado había sido
elegido por sexto año consecutivo como
el mejor chef del mundo más cuestiones
de este más precisión Es sobre este
Palmar es muy pocas mujeres pero sí
dieron bastante premios a los chefs
sobre todo a los más jóvenes incluso
para un joven belga 26 años abrió su
primer restaurante aquí en París hace
tan solo un año y pues este Joven se ha
llevado no solamente su primera estrella
sino también el premio al mejor chef
joven